[Music]
[Applause]
NFL trade deadline for
Eastern here to uh help us understand
what could happen might happen won't
happen Jeremy fer ESPN NFL reporter what
are you hearing now about anybody on the
move that could change what's going to
happen uh later this
postseason yeah certainly there's some
contending teams that are trying to get
an extra piece particularly on defense
you know pass rusher is a position
that's buzzing right now out of
Washington they're trying to sort out
Montes sweat is going to be a free agent
at the end of the year you know
Atlanta's been involved there uh so can
they get to the Finish Line on something
before 4M there's also some interesting
Chase young so Washington has a lot of
decisions to make coming up to the
deadline and then in Chicago Jaylen
Johnson really good cornerback requested
a trade eight last night and uh there's
a lot of interest but Chicago also wants
a lot from what I'm told probably would
take at least you know a good day two
pick maybe a second rounder or so and
and even change uh to get that done but
you know you got anyone from San
Francisco to to Philly to Pittsburgh
that all have had some interest in
corner Patrick ceran uh with Denver is
he
available I would be shocked I the way
it was told to me is really anybody is
available on paper but the the uh asking
price for guer T would be so obscene you
know we're talking probably multiple or
even several first round picks that it's
just he's not really available if that
makes sense it's sort of semantic so uh
I would be really really surprised if
something got done today he's not quite
Untouchable but uh not really available
either so there won't be a mcaffrey
esque trade today in your opinion I'm
not sensing that I do think one you know
big name pass rusher could get done like
a denil hunter Minnesota potentially you
know Jacksonville uh has had some
interest there uh but teams are it's
interesting right now because you saw
that Leonard Williams trade that got
done yesterday between the Giants and
the Seahawks uh you know the Seahawks
gave up a second and a fifth round pick
for him which is a pretty good haul and
the Giants had to pay his salary and so
I think because of that teams are are
they paused a little bit yesterday
thinking well if I make a trade
for a good player you know I don't want
to get embarrassed here and and not get
enough in a trade when New York just got
a lot for Leonard Williams so those are
some of the mechanics in play is
Carolina a
seller Carolina's definitely a seller
yeah I don't sense they want to move on
from Brian Burns they top pass rusher
even though there's there's been a lot
of interest there teams tried last year
they're trying again this year they love
to get their hands on them I I don't
think Carolina's going to do it but you
have other pieces like quarterback Dante
Jag
safy Jeremy Chen they got a wide
receiver Terrace Marshall that wants to
be traded you know so one of those three
names certainly could get dealt and look
if there's a team that gets desperate
enough like the Vikings or the Browns
needing a quarterback do they go after
Andy Dalton you know I think the
Panthers would move him as well but I
don't sense a lot of traction there you
know the Panthers well they sold on
Bryce
young yeah I still believe so I haven't
heard otherwise it was really early on
in the season it was a combination of
you know that they felt like there was
something a Miss with the offensive line
they were beat up there and defenses
were sort of just daring Bryce to have
to go win the game he had a lot of
responsibility on him early on and see
he just made some bad reads and some
mistakes combined with you know some
injuries and lack of weapons offensively
and threee agents not working out it was
it was really just sort of an avalanche
uh that Bryce young was a small part of
but not the the whole reason why they
were struggling on offense so um you
know he's played better the last few
weeks and showed some signs and so you
look CJ straw is looking really good of
course but I I I still feel like they're
sold on what they got and you know they
believe that with his mental capacity to
just play the position in a really smart
way they think over time he'll get
better as opposed to getting worse
trying to understand what Arizona is
doing if you have Kyler Murray do you
want Kyler Murray to play or do you uh
want him not to play and then you end up
maybe getting Drake May or Caleb
Williams
yeah that well that's that's the
million-dollar question that depends on
the perspective and they've been they've
been really hard to figure out there you
know they kind of dangle Kyler Murr or
at least last week they said we'll see
if he plays and he was a full
participant in practice but then they
listed him as doubtful and this week
that he he's already pretty much been
ruled out maybe unofficially um so it's
like how long is this going to go right
are they just G to ride this out and you
know lose games closely but lose them
conveniently knowing that you're going
to the finish line and getting maybe C
Williams or a top guy um that's a
question that I know other teams are
curious about are trying to figure out
and Arizona really hasn't had any
Clarity there I I think Kyler Murray
will play at some point U you know he's
put himself in a position to play it
doesn't really make a lot of sense to
just sit him all year um but he's not
going to have a lot around them to win
games Jeremy thanks for joining us I
know you got a busy day we appreciate
your
time hey anytime Dan appreciate it
that's Jeremy Fowler ESPN NFL reporter